Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
Perhaps you've heard that dogs are colorblind.
Now they can only see in black and white.
Well,
believe it or not,
that's not true.
Dogs are actually capable of seeing in color and today Winston here and I are
teamed up to per of that to you Winston's about to do what he's been trained to
do for about a month.
Now,
over the past month,
Winston has learned that when I say blue and he puts his paw on a blue piece of
paper,
he receives a treat that doesn't sound too complicated.
However,
if he were incapable of perceiving color,
he'd have a very hard time distinguishing between a light blue and a light
yellow.
For example,
today we'll see how he does and when we're done.
I'll explain why I chose the colors.
Blue and yellow.
Woo.
As you can see,
Winston is getting it.
He's recognizing the correct color.
Even when we substitute the colors for dark blue and orange,
he is still capable of distinguishing the colors.
Even when we add in black and white,
he still goes for the blue.
Does this suggest that Winston does in fact see the colors and is not completely
colorblind.
This is a course not the first time this has been done.
Scientists have been performing experiments and studies on things like this for
decades,
which thankfully saves them the trouble of making some rookie mistakes.
Winston can see this blue and yellow like I can,
but he and I don't see the world the same way compared to me.
Winston is a little color blind.
If I had chosen,
for example,
red and green,
Winston wouldn't be able to correctly distinguish it to this same way I do.
He would probably see them both as a kind of dark,
brownish yellow.
Why?
Well I along with all other non colorblind humans,
many species of primates and some other organisms in facts and may try Chromat
Winston along with other dogs walls and most mammals is a dye Chromat.
What does that mean?
It means that I have three different kinds of cone cells and my eyes while a
Winston has just to cone cells or just cones are the type of photo receptors
cells which allow us to see colors.
Each type of cone and a human's eye is responsible for detecting a certain
wavelength of light,
which correlates to a specific set of colors.
Humans have blue,
green and red cones and these combine to create the many kinds of colors we are
capable of seeing.
Dogs,
however,
only have two sets,
as I said,
a blue and a yellow.
The yellow is structurally in between human rat and green,
which allows them to see blue,
yellow,
and of course white,
gray and black,
but not much outside that range very well.
Our color spectrum looks like this,
but a dog's looks more like this.
Humans furthermore have 10 times the cone receptors that dogs do on average
depending on where you draw the line between a shade of an individual color and
a separate color,
humans are capable of seeing an average of 1 million colors.
Some individuals,
mostly men.
Those with a type of colorblindness are capable of seeing less and some humans,
mostly women with an extra type of cone can see even more,
perhaps even 10 times more.
The latter group fit the definition of a Tetra chromatic and they account for
about 1% of the population,
not the 25% that you may have seen from these classic clickbait articles.
The average dog in comparison to all this is capable of seeing only about 10,000
colors.
There are some humans with a kind of red green colorblindness called Protopia
that allows them to see the world.
Much like dogs do protein nopes account for about 1% of the population.
The reason for the difference between human and dog color perception is simple.
Nature is very frugal.
The ancestors of humans and many other primates needed to have the ability to
distinguish and many types of colors because of our diverse diet.
Just look for example,
at the variety of colors that fruits and vegetables can be our ability to see a
wide array of colors more than most mammals,
in fact,
helped us find where food was and helped us distinguish whether or not that food
was good to eat.
Dogs on the other hand,
have a more straight forward diet dogs,
much like their wolf ancestors are primarily carnivores,
although they are more omnivorous in walls,
diverse color perception simply is it necessary to catch a deer or a rabbit so
it's simply never evolved.
While it may seem unfortunate,
that dog's likely ability to distinguish colors that many humans do.
They do have us beat and many other fields through the combination of more rods
than humans.
Larger pupils and a tap,
a tem or a tap pay to him look Edam Latin for illuminated carpet.
They're able to see in the dark five times better than humans can.
The tap a tem is also what makes their eyes glow and pictures.
By the way,
they also have a larger field of vision and are much better at tracking motion.
Furthermore,
there are more advanced and their other senses such as smell and hearing.
Whereas humans may only be able to smell with seems like a few distinct smells.
I'm a forest food or a house.
Dogs are able to distinguish many individual smells very easily comparable to
our difference in color vision.
With all this in mind,
it's interesting to point out that technology will actually soon allow us
through gene therapy or genetic engineering to give dogs the color vision that
we humans have or perhaps enhance our vision as well.
No one has yet done this,
of course,
but perhaps some day someone will to support the creation of more videos like
these,
a link to our patriotic we found in the video description,
any donation would be appreciated and be put to use to improve the channel.
For more videos like these and videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.